a little bit but he's got great legs
fingers and all team lead defender last
year steal here for George I tell you
the VAWA Anthony's this took a lot of
punishment fix it outside Johnson saves
to play in the quarter talk to the fray
this this Thunder basketball flip this
script is right the Thunder led by 14
Clippers outscored of 18 to 3 the final
two and a half minutes is also a Western
with Carmelo Anthony out of the game 15
games full of Isis bullets gets loose
strong move by dakari Johnson offensive
rebounders too strong on the shot gonna
give it up to George George the great
with this play right here got a nice
little jump hook okay Brooke I see you
coaches like that got got yo solvers you
got a desist out of it
Wow grateful quick around the horn
Westbrook for three
[Applause]
two British 4 3 6
[Applause]
the pump fake McGeorge is equal to the
challenge
Wow great shot by George water three to
reline that that gets going in the run
to play at the end to lead by aided
halftime triple-a Insurance three-point
line that's his fourth triple at pg-13
without driving going to love this could
be pretty with battling jump in and off
rivers read the pass but then grant
steals it away from women in fact
coolers openers everybody comes to grant
[Music]
also play here 50/50 balls you have to
win those because that's what it turns
into rocketed halfway back to Tuscaloosa
George in transition Harold can't get it
to go better play was serious cover
Sabrina's outs hot for prey he's guy
Thunder taken advantage of the former
George splits the double-team wash man
for the basketball and you see the one I
want to get anybody else into a bind so
I'll spin and I'll score myself Johnson
one set into the low cost nice blue
bullet pass from George to Anthony and
he scores
timeout ruthless